in Washington Democrats and Republicans
are moving on after a long and bitter
impeachment fight but President Trump is
not ready to let it go he led an
extraordinary political rally
extraordinary because it was inside the
White House with his official supporters
lawyers and family members cheering him
on the president blasted his opponents
who impeached him and he threatened
political payback
Lygia Jiang is at the White House and
she was there for yesterday's victory
lap we should good morning what did we
learn yesterday about what might be
coming next
Oh good morning Tony and to everybody
look if anybody thought that president
Trump's acquittal would be the end of a
chapter of divisive nough sand bitter
partisanship here in Washington those
hopes were dashed yesterday and CBS News
has learned that President Trump plans
to use impeachment as a big talking
point on the campaign trail after
unleashing three years worth of
grievances he will make the case that in
order to end these so-called witch hunts
you've got to reelect him and fellow
Republicans this is what the end result
is president Trump flashed the
front-page headline for the country to
see senators found him not guilty it's
called total acquittal the speech which
the president coined a celebration
evolved into a full throttle attack of
everything from the Muller investigation
Russia Russia Russia it was to Senator
Mitt Romney the only GOP senator who
voted to convict him things can happen
when you fail so badly running for
president to the Democrats who impeached
him Adam Schiff is a vicious horrible
person Nancy Pelosi is a horrible person
before mr. Trump's remarks the House
speaker said this pray hard for him
because he's so off the track of our
Constitution the president responded
questioning her faith she may pray but
she prays for the opposite but I doubt
she prays at all former President Bill
Clinton apologized after being acquitted
in 1999 I want to say again to the
American people
how profoundly sorry I am in sharp
contrast this was the only apology mr.
Trump offered I want to apologize to my
family for having them have to go
through a phoney rotten deal and while
mr. Clinton's 1 minute 38 second address
called for unity this must be a time of
reconciliation for over an hour the
President did not these are the
crookedest most dishonest dirtiest
people I've ever seen President Trump
attacked leakers and Liars for his
impeachment but many of the people who
raised concerns about his and his
administration's actions did so in
public and under oath including
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Minh
who's CBS News has learned is expected
to be pushed out of the National
Security Council in November the
National Security Advisor said on Face
the Nation he wants to downsize but a
lawyer for ving Minh says they don't
know of any plans to move in men from
the NSC Anthony all right we just thank
you